[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
and i don't know what she used because i
checked with the doctor
my pain prescription was in there
the doctor said that it wasn't enough
jurors hear recordings of the defendant
in the missouri case of rebecca rood as
she stands trial for the murder of her
teenage daughter and the memory i'll
take away from today that i will never
forget until the rest of my walk for the
rest of my life was
hearing here and walk
into court with the chains we sit down
with abused survivors of jeffrey epstein
and his recently sentenced madam gillane
maxwell plus more delays for the
parkland school shooter as a jury is
finalized and ready for his florida
trial to begin but first r b singer r
kelly faces sentencing for his crimes
related to sex trafficking and
racketeering they said that they were
enticed by our kelly who promised them
fame a lot of them were hoping to become
celebrities themselves law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer r b artist
robert kelly known as r kelly is
sentenced to 30 years at a sentencing
hearing in a brooklyn federal court
wednesday
kelly was convicted last september on
all nine federal charges against him
including racketeering and sex
trafficking he pled not guilty and
didn't take the stand in his own defense
for his role in a scheme to recruit
women and underage children for sex
federal prosecutors requested a sentence
in excess of 25 years kelly's attorney
had asked for a shorter sentence of less
than 14 years he now faces 30 years
behind bars and a hundred thousand
dollar fine a restitution hearing is set
for september law and crime sierra
gillespie was inside the courtroom as
several survivors of kelly's abuse spoke
before the judge and to kelly
these were really emotional for a lot of
the women to get through and even for a
spectator to listen on they detailed
what they called modern day slavery they
said that they were enticed by r kelly
who promised them fame a lot of them
were hoping to become celebrities
themselves who were aspiring singers
young underage girls many of which in
the miami area who kelly reached out to
and at first they thought okay this is a
mentorship program i'm gonna learn
something and instead it's what they
called modern day slavery a lot of them
said they had been diagnosed with
depression trauma
ptsd and a lot of them said that kelly
does not show any sign of remorse this
is something that multiple of the
victims or survivors i should say
touched on they said they believe that
kelly has a god complex that he used
this to groom young women girls boys for
his own sexual gratification and many of
them said he shows no empathy even today
so many of them felt they were still
being disrespected by r kelly even at
his federal sentencing
joining us today is former swat and
detective lisa lockwood and co-host
terry austin lisa what was your reaction
to the victim impact statements we heard
a little bit of it there and how do you
think they affected the judge when
deciding r kelly's sentence
oh without a doubt it had a huge effect
on the judge
because listen there's a documentary
made a lot of these women were
participating in that we heard about dog
collars being worn we heard about
videotaping and using that uh to try to
influence them not to go forward kind of
like revenge porn there was so much
exposed in that documentary i mean
there's no doubt that the judge listened
to these
incredible survivors who had endured all
of this and really agreed that this was
the the proper way to go as far as 30
years and and throwing the book at him
yeah now terry do you think the judge
came to the right number here especially
considering what both sides are asking
for and do you and and do you think
kelly should have made a statement
you know i do think the judge came down
with the right number she looked at the
sentencing guidelines she took into
account all of the victim impact
statements and she said she even took
into account r kelly's history his
traumatic history but at the end of the
day it was what happened to those
victims she directly talked to him and
said to him what he did to those victims
and i think she decided that 30 was
sufficient but that it was necessary and
so she wanted to make sure that she gave
him a number that reflected the crimes
that he did and all of these victims all
of these survivors were very young at
the time so i think it was the right
number and he couldn't say anything
because he's facing other charges we
know he's going
in august to face charges in chicago so
he has to be careful what he says he's
also got a case in george as well so
it's a lot on the line for r kelly and
probably many more years to add to those
30 years
still ahead on law and crime daily after
nearly three months a jury is seated as
the case of the parkland school shooter
sees another delay but first we're
hearing from jeffrey epstein and elaine
maxwell's abused survivors for the first
time after the madam is sentenced to
decades in prison
[Music]
welcome back former jeffrey epstein
madame elaine maxwell was sentenced to
20 years in prison on tuesday and after
the sentencing hearing lawn crime sat
down with two of the of the pairs abuse
survivors long crime covered maxwell's
trial extensively until she was
ultimately convicted in december of five
of the six federal felony charges she
was charged with including sex
trafficking of a minor prosecutors
proved to the jury that the 60 year old
recruited and groomed young teenage
girls for longtime companion epstein who
faced similar charges back in 2019. he
was found dead by suicide in his jail
cell before his case could go to trial
maxwell did not testify in her own
defense during the trial but at her
sentencing she did address the abuse
survivors before the sentence was handed
down she acknowledged she had been
convicted but stopped short of taking
responsibility for her crimes several of
epstein and maxwell's abuse survivors
also spoke at the sentencing
long crime host michael bryant had the
opportunity to sit down with elizabeth
stein after the hearing she shared what
it was like being just feet away from
her abuser in court
this was the first time i actually saw
her
look like
a prisoner and
maybe seeing that visual not seeing
glamour escalating
seeing her
that way
also gave me
some solace
you know it's been asserted that
her meeting jeffrey epstein was the
worst mistake she ever made and it may
well be
she didn't have to choose to pass on the
trauma she didn't have to choose that
she chose
in my estimation would seem to be the
easier route it's easy to live well it's
easy to have all the things that you
want and all the friends that you want
and all the connections
you know
looking at someone's humanity is a
different thing and i just don't feel
like
she is yet able to look at
us in a humanly
we also spoke with a second survivor
sarah ransom she told us how she felt
seeing maxwell in court we want to warn
you given the nature of this case the
following sound bite has sensitive
content
the thing for me
the memory i'll take away from today
that i will never forget until the rest
of my world for the rest of my life was
hearing gear and walk
into court with the chains
and that was a very somber
but liberating moment for me because
these normal games
i just heard the clinking clink clink
think i i'm disappointed i don't feel
like yan took accountability and
responsibility really for the victims i
think that was
her addressing the victims was a bit of
a sham saying i'm sorry
i have a particular issue with i'm
saying saying
i'm sorry because
not
at one point when i was being raped
every single day
sometimes for three times a day to three
times a day
when gilean herself by her own hand
forced me into jeffrey epstein's room to
be raped
did she say i'm sorry
i've spent the last 17 years
trying to
get some form of justice
trying to
put together life
for myself
and i haven't been able to do that
until today
all right we have a former detective and
a formal civil rights attorney so i
think i'm just gonna listen and let you
two talk about your reaction to the
interviews of these maxwell survivors
terry you first
brian you know these women spoke truth
to power and you have to think about all
of the survivors of all of these
individuals who are being prosecuted now
they go through the incident and then
they have to
get the trial and it takes a long time
to get these cases prosecuted and then
they have to go through the trial and
then they have to see what happens after
the trial if there's a conviction and in
both those interviews what we heard was
we saw glenn maxwell come into that
courtroom and finally she's in chains
finally she's not wearing rich expensive
clothes so i think there's a little bit
of closure for all of these survivors
that they've finally come to the end of
this road it doesn't take away what
occurred but it does give them some
solace a little bit of closure that
these people have been prosecuted and
that they have now been sentenced to
jail
your reaction
these these ladies these women who were
once the children young ladies who were
sexually abused and
in proximity of galen during all of it
never felt at any point that galen had
their backs that glean was there to
support them to help their lives in any
way they were used as a tool
for galen in order to supply
jeffrey epstein's incredible animalistic
sex life and now after all of these
years they've tried so hard to get their
life on track because they thought maybe
one day there will be justice and now we
finally have it these women have their
justice that they were searching and now
they can move on to better heal
thank you lisa and terry coming up on
law and crime daily a jury is finalized
and the trial delayed again for the
parkland school shooter plus in missouri
prosecutors play a recording of rebecca
rue's account of discovering her
daughter's death as she faces charges
for her murder
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily in
florida a jury has been selected in the
penalty phase trial for parkland school
shooter as the case is delayed again
back in october he pled guilty to
killing 17 people in the february 2018
mass shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in parkland florida
the incident sparked nationwide
conversations about gun control measures
and mental health a 12-panel jury will
decide whether the 23-year-old should
spend the rest of his life in prison or
be put to death duros will consider
whether several aggravating factors
including his planning and cruelty
outweigh his history of mental and
emotional problems the jury of seven men
and five women finalized on tuesday was
narrowed down
over nearly three months from 1800
candidates 10 alternates were also
selected the trial which was rescheduled
to july 6 is now being pushed back and
is set to begin on july 18th
tier
why did it make sense to move the date
from the 6th of july to july 18th
was that the right move and could it be
the last move well let's hope it's the
last move brian judge shearer did say
this was going to be the last delay this
happened back in february 2018
and so now years later we are finally
getting to trial but this is the biggest
mass murder shooting that we've had that
has gone to trial and so it's very
important that they get it right and the
issue obviously is life and death so you
have to think that there will be experts
who talk about the death sentence they
want to make sure that the jury has all
the information in front of them so this
time will give them a little bit more
time to get all the information in line
and make sure that they have what they
need to do the best they can either to
you know prosecute the case or even
defend the case obviously so i think
that it made sense and it's after the
fourth of july who knows maybe it'll
give them a little break and then the
case will go forward with no further
delays yeah let's hope the potential
jurors aren't talking about the case on
the fourth of july as well but lisa as a
former law enforcement agent you must
have had to wait as cases drag on before
you can testify to get some sort of
justice for victims what do you think
it's like for the victims families to
have to wait while as justice is delayed
like this
brian it's it's excruciating this is
over four years february 14th of 2018
and just as they're getting close to to
the dates it's around the corner it's
like a carpet is being pulled out from
under them no not again not again
because 17 people we lost 14 students
three staff members and to think about
everybody surrounding those families who
just want to move on with their lives it
is the hardest thing in the world and
the court system is not as expedient as
we would like it to be but um we need to
do better
yeah
like you said like knowing that it's
coming and then saying oh no no 12 more
days or five more days like that's
that's got to be the worst well
hopefully it comes up soon when we come
back an audio recording of the defendant
is played in court in the missouri trial
of rebecca root as she faces
first-degree murder for the death of her
teenage daughter
welcome back a saint louis police
officer takes the stand in the missouri
trial of dejuan ferguson a man being
tried for the nearly two decade-old
murder of his son who had special needs
christian ferguson was just nine years
old when he went missing christian had a
rare disorder which prevented his body
from processing protein properly a
condition which needed constant medical
attention and interfered with his
ability to walk and talk prosecutors say
ferguson failed to provide his son with
proper medication for more than two
years the day christian disappeared june
11 2003 ferguson left his home with his
son and stopped to use a pay phone
moments later he called 9-1-1 to report
someone had carjacked his running suv
with christian inside the vehicle was
later found hours later just a few miles
away christian's body was never found an
officer who arrived on scene when
christian was reported missing described
his first interaction with the defendant
did you ever speak with mr ferguson yes
i did okay and when you spoke with him
what did he say to you
i heard i i can't from for 20 years
back look at it and say these are the
exact words spoken
i don't have the memory for it
but
what struck me at that time
was
he was
he was a regular victim he was every
victim that i had dealt with in all
those years he was upset
he was nervous he was pacing
also in missouri both sides rest their
case as rebecca rood faces first-degree
murder charges for the death of her 16
year-old daughter prosecutors say rude
murdered her 16-year-old daughter
savannah leckie back in 2017. savannah
had special needs and had previously
been adopted though rude's biological
daughter savannah was adopted by another
couple as a baby when she began
struggling with behavioral problems as a
teen savannah moved back in with her
biological mother rood and her boyfriend
robert p
eleven months later rude reported her
daughter missing prosecutors say rude
abused savannah and that she and pete
eventually killed her and burned her
body in june of 2017. investigators
searched their ozark county farm and
found bone fragments and teeth in a burn
pile in opening statements rude's
attorneys argued savannah killed herself
and that rude admits to burning her
daughter rood's husband and co-defendant
robert p jr testified tuesday
investigators say he turned over
recordings to them from the defendant's
interview with a member of the public
defender's office
where was the man when he went into the
camper
she went down
[Music]
try to wake her up to give her an
antibody for the infection in her hand
and
this is the manicure herself
and i don't know what she used because i
checked with the doctor
my pain prescription was in there and
gone but the doctor said that it wasn't
enough so she had been thinking
something else and i don't have any
so i don't know what she used there was
no god in the doctor
dr brian when robert took me to the
doctor to get medication for so many
giving me a prescription of vitamin
a and
i went back the next week and i asked if
that was enough to kill her and he said
no she i asked him i i don't know what
she used the only other thing i can
think of
is
i have some fly bait i use the toys and
goons but i don't know how she
this smells awful
lisa pete jr held on to these recordings
for over a year then gave it to the
police does how the police got it affect
what was said on the recording
well that's the big question right now
and it appears that they permitted that
evidence to come into court because she
willingly gave that to him and said put
this away for safe keeping and he held
on to it he said he never even listened
to it and then when he finally did
listen to it that's when he felt that he
needed to go forward with it and let's
not forget he's also charged and he also
has a trial going forward so it's very
likely that he thought that this would
help him uh in a future trial if he came
clean with this information yeah if
she's convicted and gets x amount of
years it's going to be very curious to
me at least as to what kind of plea deal
that he ultimately gets because he's
obviously testifying for something it
seems he's cooperated in some way shape
or form in many ways well terry
do you believe pete jr
i mean he came and testified
a lot of people saying it's kind of a
nothing burger but it's supposed to help
the prosecution
and orn do you think that he did it
alone that being killing savannah leckie
here's what i think brian i think the
two of them together killed savannah
there's no question that as a parent and
as a spouse taking care of a child you
are supposed to understand and know what
medications they have and you are
supposed to give those medications and
make sure there's no harm to the child
and here you see they're saying
different things we heard the defense
say in the opening statement for rood
that she didn't kill savannah but she
burned the body you don't burn a body if
you aren't involved with the killing and
now we hear pete talking about the fact
that there is this you know recording
and he's finally giving it over but he's
trying to protect himself no question
about it i think you're right about that
you have these two defendants and one is
trying to save himself and so he turns
over the recording to get himself out of
trouble all right we'll see how this
case continues like you said moving
towards closing statements well thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you